[موسيقى]
العالم بحاجه الى نظام جديد وانا اثق
ببوتين هكذا اعلنها حفيد ارطغرل فهل سينسى
الروم هذا التصريح ونقصد امريكا والغرب
واوكرانيا تغير جلدها كالثعبان فهل تنجح
هذه الاستراتيجيه وتلدغ القوات الروسيه
هذه المره وانزل نسكي يلبي الاستدعاء
الامريكي ويحط رحاله في بلاد العمسات
واختفاء غامض لاقوى الطائرات الامريكيه في
الجو وبين اذربيجان وارمينيا اندلعت الحرب
بمباركه روسيه تركيه وبعد ان قرا عاصمه
اوروبيه جديده تقف حائلا امام السويد في
الانضمام الى النيتو وبعد الحديث عن توقف
مباحثات التطبيع السعوديه توجه صفعه ساخنه
وجديده لاسرائيل تغيير الجلد الاوكراني
لقد حان وقت تغيير العالم
مجال للعوده للوراء دول العالم تقفز من
المركب الامريكي والغرب يخسر حلفائه وها
هو الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان يعلن
بان العالم بحاجه الى نظام جديد ولا يمكن
ان يبقى مستقبله مرهونا بشفاه خمس
جميع الدول اكبر من ان تكون محصوره بين
خمس دول او مرهونه برغباتها عدوى
التغييرات هذه انتقلت الى كييف وفي الداخل
الاوكراني تغييرات داخليه استراتيجيه
متتاليه بعناوين مختلفه بين محاربه الفساد
من جهه وضرورات المعركه ضد روسيا من جهه
اخرى وهي احدث مظاهر التغيير حيث اقلت
الحكومه الاوكرانيه سته نواب لوزير الدفاع
من بينهم هان مليار التي كانت تقدم افادات
متكرره من شان احدث المواجهات في الحرب مع
روسيا فهل تجدي هذه التغييرات نفعا لتحقيق
شيء ما في ارض المعركه الرئيس الاوكراني
زلنسكي رحله في الولايات المتحده بعد ان
تم استدعائه من قبل الاداره هناك ليصل الى
نيويورك حيث يلقي كلمه امام الجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده كما سيجري محادثات
مع نظير الامريكي جو بايدن بانتظار ما
الذي ستسفر عنه هذه المحادثات لكن يبدو ان
زالنسكي سيعود محملا بالهدايا هذه المره
حيث اعلن وزير الدفاع الامريكي ان دبابات
التي تعتزم الولايات المتحده امداد
اوكرانيا بها سيتم تسليمها لقواتك قريبا
من جهه اعلن وزير الدفاع الالماني بوريس
بيستوري اسامه بلده ستقدم حزمه مساعدات
جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه 400 مليون يورو
بحسب صحيفه بيلد الالمانيه ليعود حفيد
ارطغرل ويدخل على خط الحرب هذه المره
معلنا ان انقره غير ملزمه الاتحاد
الاوروبي في العقوبات ضد روسيا التي تحصل
تركيا على نصف غازيها منها وتتعاون معها
في الصناعات الدفاعيه طفا نحن نثق بها يا
لها من كلمات غاضبه فتجر احفاد ارطغرل
وعثمان الى مواجهه الغرب هذه المره فيما
اعلن سكرتير مجلس الامن الروسي نيكولاي
باتروشيف الناموسكو بانتظار محادثات
ثنائيه مفصله بين الرئيسيين الروسي
والصيني الشهر المقبل في بكين فعن اي
محادثات يتحدث والان ميدانيا هزت انفجاره
مدينه الفيف بغرب اوكرانيا وقالت السلطات
بالمنطقه انظمه الدفاع الجوي شاركت في صد
هجوم جوي روسي تسبب في حريق كبير باحد
المستودعات الصناعيه واصابه شخص احطت
السلطات المواطنين على البقاء في الملاجئ
مع توقع المزيد من الهجمات ليعلن سلاح
الجو اسقاط سبع وعشرين طائره مسيره روسيه
من اصل 30 اطلقت روسيا في هجمات متفرقه
اليكم المصدر سلاح الجمع الاوكراني اعلنت
عن اسقاط 27 مسيره الى طراز شاهد 136
وشاهد 131 لاطلقت من الجهه الشرقيه
والجنوبيه الشرقيه من الاراضي الروسيه
المحاذيه في المقابل اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تكميد القوات الاوكرانيه 600 قتيل
وجريح خلال 24 ساعه واسقاط مقاتله سو 25 و
38 مسيره اوكرانيه والعهده على المصدر كما
نتصفحه امامكم في الموقع الرسمي للحكومه
الروسيه والى معارك التحالفات والانضمامات
حيث صرح وزير الزراعه والاغذيه البولندير
لانضمام اوكرانيا الى الاتحاد الاوروبي لن
يكون ممكنا الا بعد استيفاء شروطا معينه
بشان الزراعه اي اذا التزمت اوكرانيا
بشروط الزراعه فسيتم ضمها رسميا للاتحاد
الاوروبي ايعقل هذا اما الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان فقال انه لن يكون من الممكن
الحديث عن جدول زمني للمده التي ستستغرقها
الحرب في اوكرانيا ومتى ستنتهي مضيفا ان
الزعيمي البلدين فقط هما من يمكنهما تحديد
ذلك وعلى ذكر تركيا وبعد ان عادت انقره
لتهديداتها برفض انضمام السويد الى حلف
شمال الاطلسي كشفت صحيفه
انضمت الى تركيا في وضع المزيد من العقبات
امام مساعي السويد للانضمام الى حلف
النيتو وكان رئيس البرلمان الهنجاري
لاسلكوفير الحريف المقرب لرئيس الوزراء
فيكتور غربا قد قال ان بلاده والسويد لا
تتفقان بشان القضايا الوطنيه وبالتالي لا
تنتميان نفس التحالف وفق تعبيره لننتقل
الى حرب اخرى لكن لدول المجاوره لمنطقه
الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث اشتعل فتيل حرب اخرى
باعلام اذربيجان انها شنت عمليات لمكافحه
الارهاب في
بعد نحو ثلاث سنوات من حربها على المنطقه
الجبليه المتنازع عليها مع ارمينيا مضيفه
انها تستخدم اسلحه عاليه الدقه على الخطوط
الاماميه وفي العمق في اطار العمليات
وهناك اشاره اذربيجان الى انها ابلغت
روسيا وتركيا بالانشطه العسكريه التي
تنفذها في جرابات في اطار عمليه مكافحه
الارهاب في المنطقه الانفصاليه التي
تسكنها ارمينيا فيما اعربت الخارجيه
الروسيه عن قلقها البالغ ازاء تصعيد الحاد
للوضع في اقليم كاراباخ الجبلي بين
ارمينيا واذربيجان ليعلن المتحدث
باسموف ان الروسيه على اتصال مباشر
بالجانبين الارمني والاثري على اعلى
المستويات بينما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع في
اذربيجان ان وزير الدفاع تركيا
العسكريه في كاربان الاحداث والتطورات بعد
الحديث عن توقف مباحثات التطبيع وفي رساله
سعوديه حاده لاسرائيل جاءت الرياض صفعه
ثانيه لتل ابيب حيث اكد وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان انه لن
يكون هناك حل للصراع الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي
من دون دوله فلسطينيه مستقله اقوى طائره
في سلاح الجو الامريكي تختفي فجاه حيث
اصدر قائد مشاه البحريه الامريكيه قرارا
بوقف العمل لمده يومين هذا الاسبوع لجميع
وحدات الطيران داخل وخارج الولايات
المتحده
عقب سقوط مقاتله اف 35 نيكارون لاين
الجنوبي لتعلن قاعده تشارليستون العسكريه
الامريكيه بعد ذلك ان قوات المشعه اثرت
على حطام الطائره المقاتله اف 35 واجزاء
منها قباله الطريق
بمقاطعه ويتم اغلاق الطرق بمقاطعه
[موسيقى]